[Music]  a woman if you ask her what she wants  from a man she's like I don't want much  I just want to find a nice man who's a  millionaire and six foot tall and funny  and charismatic and interesting and  spontaneous and looks after me and  doesn't she and and it's funny and good  looking and strong I don't want much  like they name all this [ __ ] that most  dudes are never gonna have and it's  becoming harder and harder and you end  up with people  top G's who own everything on the planet  they could ever possibly wish for and  then you've got other guys who have  nothing and there's this large divide  there's no longer any Middle Ground you  have dudes who can't get any [ __ ] and  then you've got dudes who are just  blocking girls out front and center and  that's what the problem with being a man  is today